[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week-end
voici les titres de ce vendredi 30 avril
le premier ministre jean castex
présidait ce vendredi la cérémonie
d'hommage national à stéphanie aime
cette agente administrative assassiné
par un terroriste il y a une semaine
un hommage qui a eu lieu à rambouillet
là où elle travaillait en présence de
nombreux ministres et élus à saint
quentin en yvelines le vaccinodromes au
vélodrome nationale sera désormais
ouvert la nuit au lieu de fermer ses
portes à 18 heures il continuera les
vaccinations jusqu'à 23 heures
notre invité jean michel fourgous
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines sera avec nous pour
faire le point sur la vaccination enfin
comme chaque semaine et même confiné
célia gars tsongo vous présentera ces
idées sorties et loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre
l'hommage national à stéphanie aime
cette agente administrative du
commissariat de rambouillet assassiné
vendredi dernier par un terroriste a eu
lieu ce vendredi 30 avril c'est le
premier ministre jean castex qui a
présidé cette cérémonie
astrid berges est raccompagné par c'est
agathe songo ont été sur place regardez
c'est ici derrière moi que vendredi 30
avril s'est tenue la cérémonie d'hommage
national à stéphanie mon fermer cette
agente administrative de la police a été
assassiné une semaine plus tôt à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici au
commissariat de police de rambouillet où
elle travaillait depuis 1993
l'émotion était vive ici cet hommage
national a été présidée par le premier
ministre
les jean castex en présence d'autres
ministres et secrétaires d'état ainsi
que des élus du territoire sa famille
était également présente sur place une
cérémonie sobre et républicaine ici sur
la place andré thomas jean castex s'est
exprimé il a rendu hommage à stéphanie
mon fermé s'il a qualifié de serviable
et doté d'un caractère horreur inutile
de dire qu'elle était toujours accueilli
à bras ouverts dans ce commissariat dans
lequel elle travaillait depuis le début
de sa carrière en 1993 où chacun la
connaissait et où elle était un peu
comme chez elle elle était d'ailleurs
partout chez ed à rambouillet après
cette prise de parole stephanie mon
fermé a reçu la légion d'honneur à titre
posthume
une minute de silence a également été
respectée par l'ensemble des personnes
sur place
après la marseillaise la famille à
quitter les lieux accompagné des
politiques sur un titre de bonnie tyler
tous
et tout cas
c'était une très jolie cérémonie qui
était digne qui était simple et qui à
mon avis ressembler
à stéphanie je crois que c'est bien que
la la république se soit déplacé chez
elle que la république se soit déplacé
comme ça dans ce territoire rural de
l'île de france
ce petit bout de france rambouillet qui
a été tellement traumatisée par cet
attentat
tellement bouleversée c'est un éclair
dans un ciel bleu autour de cette place
il y avait aussi des habitants la ville
avait installé un écran géant pour
qu'ils puissent assister à la cérémonie
on écoute leurs réactions c'est une
policière qui s'est fait tuer quelqu'un
qui représente la france qui nous qui
nous défend tous les jours il me dire
que quelqu'un lui a ôté la vie c'est
s'attaquer à la france et c'est pour ça
que je suis ici pour lui rendre hommage
et montrer à ses proches que ba est
méritée en fait cet ogre endommagé que
tous ces gens soient lents et émouvants
un très beau discours très bien très
bien
j'ai mon père qui en fait policiers donc
je voulais être là aussi pour lui et
c'est un comment dire c'est un moment
aussi qui je pense doit tous nous
rassembler et faire en sorte va de ne
pas tomber face à face à ça comme on l'a
entendu ce qui est sûr c'est que cet
acte terroriste a marqué les
rambolitains ainsi que l'ensemble de la
nation
ils n'oublieront jamais stéphanie
m'enfermer dans le reste de l'actualité
c'est désormais officiel le
déconfinement se fera en quatre étapes
le président de la république a dévoilé
le calendrier jeudi 29 avril
premier rendez vous donc de se dé
confinement progressif le lundi 3 mai
comme vous voyez s'afficher à l'écran
pas de surprise fin des limitations de
déplacements ou encore rentrée des
collégiens de 4e et de 3e et des lycées
en présentiel en demies jauge la
deuxième étape
et ça c'est une nouveauté ce sera le 19
mai le couvre-feu sera décalée à 21h et
les terrasses ainsi que les musées
cinémas monuments ou encore théâtre
pourront ouvrir leurs portes tout comme
les établissements sportifs
la troisième étape est celle qui
s'apparente le plus un réel
déconfinement ce sera le 9 juin décalage
du couvre-feu à 23h cette fois-ci
réouverture des cafés et restaurants en
intérieur mais aussi des salles de sport
des salons et foires d'exposition avec
des jauges
imitation de personnes enfin dernière
étape qui devrait marquer la levée des
restrictions le 30 juin prochain fin du
couvre-feu plus de jauge pour le nombre
de personnes en revanche les
discothèques
elles resteront fermés attention ce
calendrier est évidemment donné à titre
indicatif l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire nationales ou locales pauvres
et pour échanger ses prévisions toutes
nos informations et les précisions à
retrouver dans le 7-8 journal de lundi à
18h en direct présenté par grégory
canali et qui dit déconfinement en
quatre étapes dites aussi vaccination
qui s'accélère pour en parler avec nous
nous accueillons en vainquant
visioconférence avec nous jean michel
fourgous bonsoir bonsoir
alors le vaccinodromes saint quentin en
yvelines et très bon élève sur la
vaccination vous êtes je le rappelle le
président l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et cette
agglomération c'est la première à avoir
mis en place ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui un vaccinodromes alors ça a
été mis en place au vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines
cette semaine c'est 70 mille doses
administrées qui a été dépassée c'est un
chiffre record
au total environ 500 personnes sont
mobilisées depuis le 18 janvier dernier
pour faire jusqu'à mêmes voire plus de
3000 vaccinations par jour
justement à ce sujet nicolas dainville
maire de la verrière et vice président
de saint quentin en yvelines s'est
exprimé chez nos confrères de ces news
mercredi 27 avril dernier il a déclaré
que l'état doit rembourser les frais
engagés par les collectivités dans le
cadre de cette vaccination est ce que
c'est aussi votre souhait jean michel
fourgous et combien cela représente s'il
justement dans votre budget ce coût de
la vaccination
écoutez je crois que c'est d'encours en
à bord
l'état se prépare d'immuniser on n'a pas
exactement les chiffres pour alors pour
nous les chiffres c'est non c'est
environ un million d'euros
déjà ring pour le fonctionnement or
selon le nombre de mois je vous dirai ça
quand on a clos cette opération
deuxièmement il ya le coût du vélodrome
alors levé devant me coût de 4 millions
par an donc ça vous donne une petite
idée et ensuite vous avez le coût des
médecins ce sera environ un million
d'euros
là c'est l'état m médecins infirmiers et
il y a le prix des vaccins qui environ
qui va tourner autour d'un million
d'envois yahoo donne ça vous donne 1 2
million puisqu'être milan le prix du
plus un million de fonctionnement là ça
vous fait qu'un bêta 7 millions
quasiment donc c'est comme une opération
très coûteuse mais la vie jeudi quand
vous êtes un élu un responsable même de
plusieurs collectivités dire comment ça
s'est passé cette décision et b12
commune et douze communes à saint
quentin
soit on faisait chacun notre petit
centre de vaccination soit on le faisait
tous ensemble avec en mettant le paquet
en vraiment en termes de qualité en
termes de moyens de médecins
coordination parking de rapidité bien
sûr je suis vie administrative
c'est ce qu'on a choisi est
effectivement 50 ans est devenu un des
rôles majeurs en france donc et en même
temps le gouvernement fait un effort sur
nous disent qu'on a des doses
départemental et on a des doses
nationale effectivement permet est sûr
d'être très opération il ya une bonne
coordination
ce 30 avril le vaccinodromes passant en
nocturne c'est bien ça on va en parler
juste juste après au lieu de fermer du
coup ahadi
huit heures le centre restera ouvert
jusqu'à 23h c'est une première
500 doses supplémentaires de pfizer et
de moderna sont donc prévus pour ces
créneaux de nuit jean michel fourgous
pourquoi ce choix d'ouvrir la nuit parce
que on sort maintenant ils 60 ans mais
hélas c'était hélas je comprends que
soit le gouvernement qui gère ça parce
que c'était les plus de 65 ans qui
étaient les plus exposées puisque 90%
des décès qu'au guide sont dans les
pulsions de sapins donc mais maintenant
ce qu'on leur demande c'est qu'il nous
laisse faire on sait gérer des files
d'attentes mieux que quiconque que dire
les collectivités ont une organisation
elle gère des événements sportifs
fanbook chaleur et leur québec 300
personnes mais alors on sait on sait
faire on a quatre sites olympiques
le vélodrome à une organisation déjà
après dix ans de bons noms qu'on nous
laisse faire parce qu'il est évident que
maintenant plus vous descendez entre
guillemets vers les jeunes plus vous
avez de monde et notamment les actifs et
les actifs il faut les relancer nos
entreprises et le demandent et saint
quentin qui est un des groupes pib par
habitant en france à des plus gros après
paris bien sûr a besoin d'aider les
entreprises et tous les tous les
salariés et pour ça donc on va devoir
augmenter et c'est pour ça qu'on va
commencer à tester ce soir une première
nocturne
mais il s'est surtout faite pour les
actifs une fois qu'on aura toutes les
autorisations
on en a besoin en retrait des
autorisations ce cas là on perd du temps
on perd même des des créneaux voilà le
but de cette nuit ses deux il faut se
roder notre organisation pour qu'on soit
prêt dès qu'on a le hoquet
on va déjà commencer aussi apprendre la
semaine prochaine également
les des gens des bureaux de vote alors
ça concerne d'abord sur saint quentin on
brigue les autorisations avec les uns
avec les autres
non c'est ce que les élections
départementales et régionales qui
approchent voilà ça c'est été annoncée
par le gouvernement
voilà qui pourront se faire vacciner au
vaccinodromes merci de nous l'annoncer
justement ces nocturnes vous luttiez
elles vont ouvrir des créneaux
supplémentaires qui vont avoir une
élection partielle
bon bah donc c'est nous qui allons les
vaccinés dans les délais les plus courts
la wii comme c'est le cas par exemple à
chevreuse j'y reviens des nocturnes qui
vont ouvrir des créneaux supplémentaires
on l'a bien compris et justement est-ce
que vous souhaiteriez que la vaccination
soit ouverte à l'ensemble des personnes
majeures donc de plus de 18 ans on
souhaiterait comme dans d'autres pays je
crois que quelqu'un allemagne maintenant
qu'on a réglé le problème de la partie
la plus sensible et plus de 105 ans
qu'on nous laisse faire on sait faire
les critères on a résumé des critères
des sous critères qui ralentissent les
files d'attentes qui ralentissent le
travail des médecins des infirmiers
voilà pour la alors on va prendre il
faut très vite qu'on ait au moins
l'autorisation des plus de 50 ans
jacques ccco
d'autant plus que tous les centres
laisse passer les plus de 50 ans
aujourd'hui donc certaines femmes et
doit des règles qui ne sont pas adaptés
aux réelles parce que les gens qui sont
sur le réel
il appelait car acquitté donc il faut il
faut faire quand conformer en les deux
bons donc une fois qu'on a ça et je
pense que ça va dans les gens qui
viennent et bien des lancements vont
avoir beaucoup plus de monde qui vont se
proposait en à dr lipton qui nous aident
à gérer ça mais on est prêt il ya merci
jean michel fourgous d'avoir été avec
nous pour parler vaccination pour 7,8
week-end je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et après une semaine
bien chargée quoi de mieux que de se
détendre le week end
comme chaque vendredi et même pendant le
confinement s'il ya 400 go vous propose
ses sorties loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons parler à
alimentation avec l'arrivée des beaux
jours vous avez peut-être envie de vous
lancer dans des plats plus sain et plus
d'équilibré
odette ada de coach en nutrition à
versailles vous a concocté une recette
simple et fraîche
les quantités sont destinés à deux
personnes le reportage de mélanie poker
et mickaël est lui trop haut la main à
la poche si team academy
venez avec moi à préparer une salade de
saison
je
[Musique]
on va commencer par l'enchère coûts et
les petits pois trois minutes dans l'eau
doit laver les épinards si vous utilisez
ce type de finales des grandes feuilles
sont là juste laisser penser il faut lui
rendre un peu plus agréable en bouche
ensuite je m'occupais des taillez les
courgettes en tagliatelles donc pour
cela vous pouvez soit utiliser une
économie où on peut aussi utiliser une
mandoline
on va faire sauter rapidement les
asperges avec un petit peu d'huile
d'olive et de l'ail écrasé dans une
poêle de les couper en biseau dans une
poêle qui est déjà bien chaude
je rajoute les asperges et après je
rajoute c'est vraiment le faire sauter
trois minutes pour préparer la sauce on
va simplement et mixer tous les
ingrédients dans son plein air donc on
va commencer par notre avocat
on va faire 1 40 g des noix de cajou 2
cuillères à soupe d'huile d'olive
procuration de ta mamie on va mettre au
ban
dans une bonne poignée de basilic les
jus d'un citron 1 citron et demi je
rajoutais juste un petit peu d'eau pour
aider les tours s'immiscer
[Musique]
maintenant je rajoute mes petits pois
et je rajoute la soci on va passer le
dressage
[Musique]
dans la gt3 fraises j'ai rajouté aux
asperges et puis j'aime bien finir avec
un petit peu d'écrits mais c'est ça non
voilà notre salade et les prêtres ça
nous a pris peut-être quinze minutes
pour l'après pariez vous avez un plaqué
coloré qui est frais qui est des saisons
je suis sûr que vous allez vous regarder
la course à la présidence nouveau jeu de
société créée par un bruyant courtois le
but est d'incarner un candidat à une
élection et la remporter coûte que coûte
une cagnotte en ligne a été lancée il ya
trois semaines pour financer ce jeu le
reportage d'astrid bergère participer à
une campagne présidentielle et tenter de
remporter une élection c'est le but du
nouveau jeu de société la course à la
présidence créé par un habitant de
guyancourt l'idée lui est venue liens
non je pense que le premier confinement
l'a tous vécu différemment nous on a
fait pas mal de jeux de société monde à
tournon avec les jeux qu'on avait et au
bon moment je suis dit pourquoi pas
essayer de créer un jeu
moine donc donc je les fais je me suis
lancée on a fait quelques parties on a
bien mené et
voilà comment c'est venu à partir de 12
ans entre deux et six personnes peuvent
jouer le but
incarnez un candidat et réussir par tous
les moyens à remporter des électeurs au
fur et à mesure du tout on va devoir
prendre la décision à chaque à chaque
moment de notre campagne finalement de
prendre tel ou tel investissement pour
développer sa stratégie de campagne
donc ça va être soit via des promesses
politiques soit via des actions ou des
descartes coups bas pour aller attaquer
les adversaires le but n'est pas
d'éduquer à la politique mais simplement
de jouer et avec beaucoup de second
degré le jeu est disponible en
précommande sur un site de financement
participatif en attendant sa sortie en
magasin
si tout va bien donc je vais les
recevoir à partir de septembre si si si
les délais sont respectés
je pourrais d'être directement d'envoyer
dans certaines boutiques partenaires qui
accepteront de les vendre donc déjà dans
l'est dans les boutiques aux alentours
il a proféré à mesure toutes les
boutiques qui seront intéressés
la gagnante walling lancé il y a deux
semaines a déjà atteint 80 % de son
objectif
dimanche 2 mai c'est la journée mondiale
du rire le rire procure de nombreux
bienfaits de sérieuses thérapies sont
même proposés carole le fortuna bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes musicothérapeute et
formatrice en louga du rire alors avant
de parler donc de vos activités
cette première question nous sommes en
pleine crise sanitaire
est ce que vous pensez qu'on rigole le
moins et surtout est-ce que c'est grave
alors on rigole moins ça c'est certain
et c'est pour ça que nous sommes là mais
moi et les autres professeurs animateurs
de yoga du rire pour combat pour libérer
le rire de tous et oui c'est grave de
paris re c'est grave parce
qu'aujourd'hui rapporte tellement de
bien fait à notre corps à votre esprit
et à notre relation que qu'il est
important de rire
et justement quels sont les bienfaits du
rire et rire tous les jours alors le
dock les les bienfaits sont nombreux ils
sont nombreux on va d'abord ce qu'on
appelle ce que j'appelle moi délivrer la
dose de bonheur c'est à dire des livres
et des hormones qui nous font du bien de
la dopamine de l'ocytocine de la
sérotonine et de l'endorphine alors ce
sont des hormones qui permettent de
trouver la motivation et on en a besoin
en ce moment qui permettent aussi de
créer des relations saines alors comme
on est en manque de relations saines
et ça montre aussi ocytocine d'ailleurs
on l'appelle l'hormone du canada on en a
besoin en ce moment parce qu'on peut pas
se toucher
on ne peut pas vraiment se rencontrer
donc c'est nécessaire de la libérer la
sérotonine qui permet elle de se sentir
plus important est d'éviter la
dépression et puis l'endorphine qui
permet d'atténuer la douleur donc ses
bienfaits sont importants en plus de
cette dose de bonheur le yoga du rire
permet d'avoir une oxygénation complète
en oxygène jusqu'au cerveau puisqu'on
veut s'appuyer sur une respiration
abdominale et puis faire un énorme
travail du diaphragme et de respiration
donc du coup qu'est ce que ça entraîne
ça entraîne une tonification du système
cardiaque
ça entraîne aussi une aux tirs et
d'oxygénation du système sanguin
donc ça c'est pour le corps et pour
l'esprit et bien qu'est ce que c'est bon
de pouvoir rire qu'est ce que ça fait du
bien de lâcher toutes ces émotions vous
votre société s'appelle communes y sont
vous aidez donc les entreprises ou
particuliers à s'épanouir
concrètement quelles techniques vous
utilisez alors j'utilise le yoga du rire
parce que le yoga du rire en entreprise
entre autres favorise la cohésion des
équipes favorise la créativité
j'utilise aussi tous les outils de
libération de la vois pas ce que la voix
ce sont celles là c'est l'expression de
son être et donc on la retrouve aussi
dans le yoga du rire et j'utilise aussi
les applications de musicothérapie vous
vous parlez de yoga du rire mais
finalement qu'est ce que c'est que le
yoga du rire alors déjà si vous voulez
je peux vous dire quand est ce que ça a
été créé c'est une pratique qui a été
créée en 1995 par un médecin indien le
docteur madan kataria et celui ci s'est
appuyé sur de nombreuses études
scientifiques score défaite sur le rire
thérapeutique
donc le yoga du rire c'est juste si je
le résume c'est de la mécanique du rire
on va rire sans faire appel à l'humour
parce que l'humour n'est pas universelle
donc on va faire de la mécanique c'est à
dire que l'on va faire travailler ici
comme je l'expliquais de thaler le
diarra n'y voyez pas besoin de raconter
une blague
on va faire de la mécanique et dès
l'instant où on met en place cette
mécanique la même si nous n'avons envie
de rien naturellement il faut savoir que
le corps ne fait pas de différence entre
un reer simulé à rire naturel c'est
prouvé scientifiquement et qu'en plus au
bout de 15 minutes de rire simuler ou
naturels le corps prend tous les
bienfaits que j'ai citées précédemment
et est ce que vous vous avez prévu
peut-être quelque chose pour cette
journée mondiale du rire oh oui et je
suis pas la seule à avoir prévu quelque
chose
donc nous sommes de nombreux nombreux à
travers le monde de nombreux clubs à
mettre en place des actions de séance
par zoom par internet et là précisément
moi je vais intervenir pour l'institut
du yoga du rire santé en france donc je
vous donne rendez vous à d'ailleurs je
crois que vous avez eu les coordonnées
pour les passer je vous donne rendez
vous le 2 mai à 10 heures du matin pour
rire avec différents animateurs de yoga
du rire
l'ouverture se fera avec le docteur
madan kataria qui nous passera ses
messages voilà pour nous c'est une
journée très importante parce que ça
nous permet vraiment de balayer le monde
entier avec le rire et ça c'est génial
on va passer le rire de la france vers
l'italie vers l'angleterre
voilà ça va être merveilleux et bien
c'est noté merci beaucoup
reporté mais d'avoir été notre invité
est le 7-8 week-end de continuer avec
lots nord pour parler de l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour refermer 7,8 week-end votre rendez
vous comme chaque semaine en partenariat
avec les surligneurs on écoute vincent
couronne docteur en droit à l'université
versailles saint quentin et fondateur
des surligneurs
en terme de buzz c'est réussi et les
réactions sont fortes
un quarteron de généraux en retraite
pour reprendre l'expression du général
de gaulle a publié une tribune dans la
presse pour dénoncer le délitement de la
france sous l'effet distille de
l'islamisme ou encore d'un antiracisme
dont l'objectif serait une guerre
raciale et appelant de façon à peine
voilée les militaires encore en poste à
se dresser contre ce délitement or
participer à un mouvement
insurrectionnel ou même seulement
l'encourager et puni par le code pénal
et c'est sur ce fondement que jean luc
mélenchon en tant qu'autorité publique
fait usage de son devoir de saisir le
procureur de la république en note au
passage que c'est le même jean luc
mélenchon qui twittait dans un contexte
de heurts entre j les jeunes et forces
de l'ordre que l'insurrection est un
droit et un devoir mais ce qui est dit
dans cette tribune relève t-il du code
pénal une phrase précise a pu être
interprétée comme un appel au coup
d'état
je cite si rien ne change disait
généraux il faudra que les militaires en
activité agissent pour protéger nos
valeurs civilisationnelles et
sauvegarder nos compatriotes sur le
territoire national fin de citation
est-ce véritablement une incitation à
quoi que ce soit ou simplement du
catastrophisme de bistrot aux mots
soigneusement pesé en tout état de cause
un juge n'aurait pas le droit d'aller
lire entre les lignes pour trouver un
délit à tout prix l'appel implicite au
cou l'état paraît bien difficile à
extrapoler juridiquement de cette
tribune même si médiatiquement il faut
le dire c'est un succès reste que ces
anciens généraux ont enfreint le code de
la défense sur le devoir de réserve des
militaires et sont passibles de
sanctions disciplinaires
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a annoncé le chef
d'état major des armées le général
lecointre
oh
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi et même confiné passé
une très bonne soirée un très bon week
end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]